THIS JUST AND, AUTHORITIES ARE
LOOKING FOR THE CAUSE OF AN
EXPLOSION THAT ROCKED ATHENS
GREECE EARLIER TODAY.
REUTERS REPORTS IT TICKS SEVEN
FIRE ENGINES TO PUT OUT THE
FLAMES ON THE BUILDINGS
AFFECTED.
YOU CAN SEE ENTIRE WALLS BLOWN
OUT AND THE SIDE OF THE
BUILDINGS HERE, COVERED IN SUIT
AND ASH.
THE BLAST DAMAGED BUILDINGS UP
TO 200 METERS AWAY, AT LEAST
ONE PERSON HAS BEEN TAKEN TO
HOSPITAL, WITH REPORTED
INJURIES.
THE BLAST COMES AS PARTS OF
GREECE AND TURKEY ARE DEALING
WITH HEAVY SNOWFALL.
IT'S CAUSE POWER OUTAGES,
FORCED BUSINESSES TO CLOSE, AND
STRANDED THOUSANDS OF DRIVERS.
CNN'S ABBY DAMON REPORTS FROM
SNOWDEN SPOT IN ISTANBUL.
>>
ISTANBUL'S FAMOUS LANDMARKS
WERE BLANKETED WITH SNOW AS
PARTS OF IT HIT TURKEY.
IT'S A PRETTY SIGHT TO BELOW
HOLDS FOR THE CITY 60 MILLION
PEOPLE, BUT A NIGHTMARE FOR
TRAVELERS.
THE HEAVY SNOW CLOCKS ROADS
LEAD TO SOME 4600 MOTORISTS
STRANDED ACROSS TURKEY, WHILE
BUSES AND VARIES WERE ALSO
DELAYED.
PRIVATE VEHICLES WERE BANNED
FROM ISTANBUL STREETS AS
CLEANUPS BEGAN.
SNOWFALL BEGAN LATE LAST WEEK,
BUT A SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
IN RECENT DATES.
AT THE AIRPORT, FLIGHTS WERE
SUSPENDED FOR A SECOND DAY
TUESDAY.
TURKISH AIRLINES CANCELED ALL
FLIGHTS FROM THEIR AIRPORT,
WHICH TEMPORARILY CLOSED
OPERATIONS.
WORKERS PLOW THE SNOW COVER
TARMAC.
WELL INSIDE, PASSENGERS TRIED
TO MAKE THEMSELVES COMFORTABLE
WHEREVER THEY COULD.
SOME WERE SO UPSET, THEY STAGE
A PROTEST CHANTING, WE NEED A
HOTEL.
BUT ANGRY TRAVELERS APPEAR TO
HAVE CALMED DOWN AFTER AIRPORT
STAFF GAVE PASSENGERS FOOD AND
SLEEPING PODS.
AIRPORT WORKERS TRY TO ASSESS
THE DAMAGE AFTER THE HEAVY SNOW
CAUSED THE ROOF OF A CONDO
WAREHOUSE TO COLLAPSE.
IN GREECE, THE WINTER STORM
DUMPED EIGHT CENTIMETERS OF
SNOW ON ATHENS, A RARE
OCCURRENCE FOR THE CAPITAL,
KNOCKING OUT POWER TO MUCH OF
THE CITY, AS THE BLIZZARD
CONDITIONS CAUSED CHAOS ON THE
ROAD PLACE.
RESCUE CREWS INCLUDING THE ARMY
HOW THEY GOT DRIVER STUCK IN
THEIR CARS OVERNIGHT.
MANY WERE GIVEN FOOD AND WATER
AS THE TEMPERATURES FELL.
>> WE WERE ALL TRYING TO MOVE
OUR CARS FORWARD, INCH BY INCH,
BUT WE COULD.
THEN I GOT STUCK HERE LAST
NIGHT.
AT LEAST I THINK, I LOST TRACK
OF TIME.
WE MANAGED TO OFFER THEIR 50
METERS AND THAT'S IT.
I'VE BEEN RIGHT HERE SINCE LAST
NIGHT.
>> SOME DID TRY TO MAKE THE
MOST OF THE SITUATION, LIKE
THIS WOMAN WHO USED THE SKIS TO
GET AROUND.
MONDAY'S STORM ALSO TRIGGERED A
RARE SNOW NATO, OR SNOWY FUNNEL
CLOUD ACROSS SCOPE AND'S ISLAND,
AFTER A WATERSPOUT MOVED
ONSHORE.
>> THINGS HAVE BEEN QUITE MESSY
ACROSS GREECE AND TURKEY TO SAY
THE LEAST, OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS.
THE REGION IS NOT USED TO THIS
LEVEL OF SNOW.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE EAST,
RIGHT NOW THE MAIN ROADS ARE
OPEN, BUT THEY'RE SEEING HOW
HARD IT IS TO GET THOSE
SIDESTREETS CLEANED UP TO
TRAFFIC AS WELL.
I'M BASICALLY EFFECTIVELY
SNOWED IN.
TO JUST GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF HOW
RARE THIS IS, ISTANBUL H